bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france donc c'est une
journée avec des surprises aujourd'hui
lors du procès en destitution de donald
trump et au sénat puisque on la prend
juste à l'instant les démocrates et la
défense de donald trump ont trouvé un
accord qui permet donc d'éviter la
convocation de témoins et d'avancer par
conséquent dans le procès de donald
trump qui pourrait donc aboutir à un
verdict peut-être dans la journée
cet accord justement ce qu'on s'y
attendait non c'était c'est un procès
qui est plein de rebondissements comme
comme les élections étaient elles mêmes
le plein de rebondissements lorsqu'elles
se sont déroulées les c'est l'intérêt de
personne que le que le procès dure trop
longtemps et donc la convocation des
témoins le fait que le sénat ait décidé
par 55 voix contre 45 de convoquer des
témoins était une surprise
il est finalement moins étonnant que
qu'un accord ait été trouvé puisque les
démocrates ont intérêt à ce que le
prends le progrès le sénat puisse
reprendre ses activités normales pour
mettre en place la politique de
l'administration maiden et puis les
républicains bien entendu auront intérêt
à éviter que ce procès traîne en
longueur parce que c'est quelque chose
qui est qui divise beaucoup à
l'intérieur de leur camp juste un mot
peut-être sur sept a élu démocrate ça a
été vraiment le coup de théâtre de la
journée qui est donc convoqué pour
témoigner
finalement est donc cet accord c'est
jamie herrera butler c'est l'une des dix
républicain avoir voté pour a déclenché
la procédure d' impeachment
à l'encontre de donald trump qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire sur elle alors
effectivement c'est une des dix
représentants qui ont voté pour sa mise
en accusation donc didier républicain
sur sur environ 201 et alors ce qu'elle
a dit ces cas là elle a été informée
d'une conversation entre kevin mc
antilles qui est le leader des
républicains à la chambre et donald
trump le soir du 6 janvier le soir de la
prise d'assaut du capitole et que donald
trump au cours de cette conversation
aurait pris le parti en quelque sorte
des insurgés un il aurait dit à kevin
mccarthy que visiblement le résultat des
élections
dérangé plus des insurgés qu'ils me
dérangeait ce leader républicain et est
donc c'est évidemment un point important
pour le procès puisque la question est
de savoir si donald trump a incité c'est
ses partisans à la prise d'assaut du
capitole donc ce témoignage tendrait à
prouver que donald trump été et était en
tout cas le voyez cet assaut d'un oeil à
ces sympathiques
en tout cas la déposition donc de cette
élue républicaine a été lue en séance et
versé au dossier on attend maintenant
que chaque les conclusions de chaque
partie mais ce qu'on ne comprend pas
bien finalement c'est pourquoi les
démocrates ont voulu cet accord ont
signé cet accord aujourd'hui avec la
défense de donald trump
il est peu probable que qu'un tel
témoignage souhaite nature aa a ramené
les 17 voix de deux sénateurs
républicains qu'il faudrait pour que
trump soit soit condamné et puis encore
une fois les démocrates ont intérêt à ce
que le sénat puisse reprendre ses
activités normales de manière par
exemple à examiner la proposition de loi
de soutien à l'économie que il donne
opposé donc il est important pour les
démocrates que le retour à la normale se
fasse alors ce retour à la normale et
pourrait se faire rapidement dès ce soir
avec le verdict peut-être tombe
aujourd'hui
oui on a l'impression qu'on est dans la
phase finale puisque maintenant chaque
parti va avoir deux heures pour
représenter ses arguments finaux et le
vote aura peut-être dû ensuite donc il
ne serait pas étonnant que la décision
soit prise dans la soirée hors de france
en fin de journée aux états unis et le
gagnant finalement de ce bras de fer a
c'est une question parce que finalement
si sim trump n'est pas condamnée comme
ce sera probablement le cas
ses partisans ont beau jeu de dire voyez
il ya eu un impeachment qui a eu un
procès mais c'était une manoeuvre
politique et reims n'était pas coupable
s'il était condamné ce qui est moins
probable et bien semblé être un martyr
de l'establishment et c'est quelque
chose qui façon égale merci beaucoup à
vous didier combo je rappelle que vous
êtes spécialisé états unis auteur de
l'ouvragé tramèr et qu'un aujourd'hui
les enjeux d'une élection présidentielle
aux éditions gallimard